A NASA
task force is holding
its first meeting on UFOs.
Public meeting,
I should say UFO owes
or as the professionals call them,
you a piece that stands for unidentified
anomalous phenomena.
A group of experts
who spent nine months studying
the data on these UAPS.
They are sharing their findings
including, I am told, brand new video.
CNN's Tom Foreman
has been watching
all the dramatic twists
and turns in this hearing.
Tom, what do you tell us
what you've learned?
Can you imagine the excitement, John,
when they showed this video?
I want to show it to you now
where it was taken
by one plane
and they saw against the night sky.
Those three little dots there.
Look at them.
They're moving in concert.
The airplane that spotted them
said we don't know what that is.
They tried to chase it down.
They could not chase it down.
And this was rolled out today.
And now spoiler alert,
the NASA's scientists studied this
and eventually they said
we put all the evidence together.
What this was, was three
commercial aircraft
in a typical flight corridor.
The reason they couldn't chase them down
is because they're much further away.
Than they thought.
And they were simply lit up that way.
The movement that you see there,
that's the plane
taking the pictures over that distance.
That's why
it looks like they're
moving back and forth.
So their point is to say
there's a lot of stuff out there
which actually can be explained
if you can get enough information.
They did say
there are some typical
reported characteristics of UAPS.
When you look at all of these out there
and this was sort of interesting
and this is report
is what people say they saw.
They typically say they are round
in small they tend to be white,
silver or translucent.
They tend to be somewhere between
ten and 30,000 feet in the air,
either stationary
or up to mock
two or twice the speed of sound
and no thermal exhaust.
But here's the problem
with all of that, John.
The problem with that
is that is largely anecdotal.
That's just people saying
that's what they saw
or is being measured
with all sorts of crazy
different instruments out there.
And here's what's important.
There are a lot of these reports.
Listen to
what was said at this conference
about the sheer volume of these reports
that are coming in.
At the time of my open hearing,
we were at 650 cases
ish we roughly get
I mean, you can do the math,
you know,
it depends anywhere from from 50 to
100 ish new reports a month.
Now, the reason we had such a big jump
recently is because I got FAA data
integrated in finally.
And so we ended up with like 100
some odd new cases.
The numbers I would say that we see are
possibly really anomalous
or a less than single digit
percentages of those
So, John,
the real issue here
that NASA's saying is what we really need
is a plan going forward, a way
to systematically
take that tremendous
amount of information.
All those videos,
all those reports, all those claims,
and somehow
subject them
to the kind of scientific rigor
that NASA is known for
and maybe a lot of this
will become explained.
But through all of this, again,
nobody is yet saying
at the government level
that they think
any of this is from outer space.
Maybe advanced weapons
systems, maybe new communications
or travel systems.
Some of it may just be mysteries,
but they don't think it's aliens.
It does sound like this hearing
maybe had a little
higher dose of skepticism
than some of the other speculation there.
We had that wonderful
chart up on the screen
where you had the characteristics
of these side
sightings
and the last one was no thermal exhaust.
Well, I'm wondering then
if these are all electric
vehicles, right?
I mean, you know, like like a Tesla
has no tailpipe.
Maybe maybe the
you know, the Martians are using EVs.
Well, maybe
maybe they
were you would think they might be
a little more advanced than us
because after all, they made it here.
We didn't make it there.
Are range anxiety, right?
If they were Avs,
they won't be able to get this far
because of the range issues.
Yeah, it's great.
I will say,
when you say skepticism,
I don't even know
if it's skepticism, John,
as much as it is.
These are scientists who are saying
science can explain this stuff,
but you can't explain it
based on a shaky iPhone video.
That somebody took while camping.
You need something more involved.
And that means coordination
of actual scientific.
Yeah. Yeah.
This is why Bigfoot is still missing
right here. What's going to turn out?
It's going to turn out.
It's going to turn out that bigfoot.
Gentlemen, I'm jumping into this.
We're jumping into this.
What do you mean?
We can't
we can't solve all the questions.
Of the universe on my shaky
so we can try having tom.
Personally, I think what
they're going to find out.
I heard this somewhere.
They're going to find out.
The Bigfoot, for example,
is actually a blurry creature.
Is.
Why don't we look at the
flying spaceships?
They're already very grainy.